[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis samstagabend bekommt zu
den nachrichten im sport hat norbert
könig unter anderem fußball für sich
genommen was uns in dieser sendung an
großen themen beschäftigt das sehen sie
jetzt
politischer spagat fdp chef lindner
stark dem kanzler den rücken
gleichzeitig fordert er auf dem
parteitag schwere waffen für die ukraine
schwere kämpfe in der ost ukraine
russland nimmt viele städte unter
dauerbeschuss die offensive kommt aber
offenbar nur langsam voran und
weniger hass und hetze im netz die eu
einigt sich auf ein gesetz das internet
konzerne bald stärker regulieren soll
schwere waffen an die ukraine liefern ja
oder nein diese frage beschäftigt auch
die fdp auf ihrem parteitag
parteichef christian lindner ist dafür
und gibt sich überzeugt die ukraine wird
diesen krieg gewinnen
gleichzeitig stellte sich lindner hinter
kanzler scholz dem weil
waffenlieferungen ja zögerlichkeit
vorgeworfen wird über eine schwierige
balance britta buchholz aus berlin
die ukraine dominiert den parteitag
schon am morgen junge liberale prangern
die bisherige politik gegenüber russland
an besonders im fokus die verbindung der
spd die fdp will per antrag die
lieferung von waffen und rüstungsgütern
festlegen der antrag ist dezidiert
deutlich dass wir schwere waffen liefern
das wie kaskaden haft rausgehen aus der
energie- und ich glaube es ein wichtiges
zeichen der parteitag diskutiert stunden
über die wege in diesem konflikt lindner
wegen einer corona erkrankung nur
digital zugeschaltet mahnt gemeinsam mit
den nato partnern zu handeln wir müssen
alles was in unserer macht steht tun um
der ukraine zum sieg zu verhelfen
aber die verantwortungs ethische grenze
ist die gefährdung unserer eigenen
sicherheit
gleichzeitig nahm er den bundeskanzler
demonstrativ in schutz scholz habe das
vertrauen der gesamten fdp kritik vor
allem an der union der parteipolitische
manöver vorwirft
emotional wurde der neue fdp
generalsekretär
er kam als 11 jähriger ohne eltern
während des irak krieges nach
deutschland all diejenigen menschen die
in ihrem leben einen krieg persönlich
miterleben mussten wie beispielsweise
derzeit die menschen in der ukraine
wissen für den rest ihres lebens welches
schreckliche leid krieg mit sich bringt
und wie wertvoll frieden ist
gewählt mit 89 prozent ein deutliches
signal
auch am abend dominiert die ukraine dem
parteitag die debatte um die
waffenlieferungen dauert zur stunde noch
an
und vor ort beobachtet ralf schumacher
für uns den parteitag greift das sind ja
wirklich widersprüchliche signale der
fdp auf der einen seite will man weiter
druck machen für die lieferung schwerer
waffen ralf ich hoffe du kannst du uns
hören ich stelle die frage noch mal ja
das sind ja wirklich widersprüchliche
signale die man da von der fdp mit
bekommt auf der einen seite wollen die
liberalen druck machen bei der lieferung
schwerer waffen auf der anderen will man
den koalitionsfrieden waren wir wollen
die liberalen diesen spagat meistern
tja die fdp die sieht sich als treibende
kraft in der ampel die ukraine soll
offensive unterstützt werden auch mit
schweren waffen aber im rahmen von
bündnis absprachen und ohne die
bundeswehr zu schwächen christian
lindners deutliches bekenntnis zum
kanzler und zur koalition bremst allzu
forsche forderungen aus den eigenen
reihen und ist zugleich eine abfuhr an
die union die frage der
waffenlieferungen im bundestag als
machtprobe mit der regierung zu
inszenieren winter waren vor
parteipolitischen manövern und mahnt zur
versachlichung der debatte und trotzdem
die fdp als kleinster ampel partei ringt
um ihre rolle und immer wieder auch um
aufmerksamkeit prescht vor gibt kontra
zeigt sich unnachgiebig aktuell sicher
ein stück weit den wahlkämpfen in
schleswig holstein und nordrhein
westfalen geschuldet auf dauer durchaus
auch mit sprengkraft für die ampel
diese einschätzungen ralf schumacher
auch beim fdp-parteitag das bestimmende
thema also der ukraine krieg
international laufen die bemühungen den
krieg zu beenden
kommende woche will un-generalsekretär
ish sowohl in russland mit präsident
putin als auch in der ukraine mit
präsident seelands gesprächen die
russische großoffensive auf den osten
des landes geht unvermindert weiter
anton kuscheligen
feuer in einem krankenhaus in der stadt
bonn jetzt die klinik soll von einer
russischen rakete getroffen worden seien
moskaus truppen verstärken massiv ihre
angriffe im don was die ukrainisch
kontrollierten gebiete stehen offenbar
unter dauerbeschuss
die russischen streitkräfte haben mehr
als 1000 militärische ziele in der
ukraine angegriffen so der sprecher des
verteidigungsministeriums die schwersten
angriffe zielen demnach auf die
großstadt verio donetsk im gebiet
lugansk europäischen partner und marina
werden bombardiert nördlich davon
versuchen die russischen truppen bei ist
um weiter nach süden vorzustoßen um die
ukrainischen truppen einzukesseln
laut britischen geheimdienst kommen sie
aber kaum voran weil das ukrainische
militär weiter heftigen widerstand
leistet der ukrainische präsident warnte
erneut der einmarsch russlands in die
ukraine sei nur der anfang
alle völker die wie wir an den sieg des
lebens über den tod glauben müssen mit
uns kämpfen sie müssen uns helfen denn
wir sind die ersten in der reihe und wer
wird der nächste sein fragt sie lenski
und reagiert damit auf aussagen des
russischen militärs von gestern demnach
sei das ziel die vollständige kontrolle
über den don bass und den süden der
ukraine um dann die republik moldau ins
visier zu nehmen die ukraine wäre dann
komplett vom schwarzen meer
abgeschnitten in der belagerten
hafenstadt mario pohl ist heute erneut
ein versuch gescheitert zivilisten zu
evakuieren nach ukrainischen angaben
haben dass russische truppen verhindert
moskau hatte bereits vor zwei tagen die
komplette eroberung von mario pohl
verkündet doch allem anschein nach
leisten ukrainische einheit immer noch
widerstand
und in der ukraine ist unser reporter
dominic löschmeister dominik wie
reagiert die ukrainische regierung auf
die aussagen eines russischen vize
kommandeurs neben dem osten der ukraine
auch teile moldaus einnehmen zu wollen
ja der ukrainische präsident selensky
sagte das könnte nur der anfang sein die
sorge ist dass die russen nicht nur den
don bosco bahn wollen sondern auch den
süden der ukraine und hier speziell die
hafenstadt odessa und das heißt ja von
den russischen zaren gegründet worden
hat also auch für die russen eine
symbolik und eine bedeutung und wenn das
so wäre in diesem szenario dann würde es
auch eine verbindung geben zur teil
republik transnistrien
das ist gehört eigentlich zur republik
moldau wird aber von den russen
kontrolliert das direkt im grenzgebiet
zur ukraine
und da ist natürlich jetzt die sorge
groß dass das verbunden wird und die
moldauer selbst das kein nato-mitglied
wir zum beispiel polen oder das baltikum
und deswegen ist dort die regierung noch
alarmiert und präsident selensky betonte
an der stelle noch einmal wie wichtig es
ist schwere waffen zu bekommen weil die
ukraine würde europas frieden
verteidigen danke damokles meister aus
der ukraine
ihr seid haben kommt die russische
großoffensive ost ukraine nur langsam
voran woran das liegt und welche rolle
schwere waffen bei den kämpfen spielen
können sie nachlesen auf zdf heute und
in der zdf- heute
mehr waffen für die ukraine das fordert
auch eine ukrainische delegation die
seit tagen quer durch europa reist heute
war sie zu besuch in nordrhein westfalen
teil der delegation ist ivan fedorov
mitte märz war der bürgermeister eine
besetzte stadt melle topoi im süden der
ukraine von russischen soldaten entführt
und wieder freigelassen worden thomas
münten hat ihn getroffen
fast wirkt ein bisschen verloren mit
seinem olivgrünen parka zwischen dem
edlen gekleideten empfangskomitee im
düsseldorfer landtag die waren fedorov
bürgermeister der von der russischen
armee besetzten stadt metropol in seine
stadt zurück kann er nicht aber werben
kann er für mehr und schnellere
militärische hilfe für die ukraine
wenn ich eher die fans wir brauchen
verteidigung jetzt um die situation an
der front zu verändern wir hätten es
gestern gebraucht jetzt wäre das auch
noch gut aber morgen ist es vielleicht
viel viel zu spät
jd der 33 jährige der im märz von
russischen soldaten aus seinem rathaus
verschleppt und tagelang gefangen
gehalten wurde hier bilder einer
überwachungskamera hat keine zeit für
diplomatische zurückhaltung
was kann politik sind unterwegs um die
deutschen politik um eine klare
entscheidung zu finden stehen sie auf
seiten der kabine oder auf seiten der
russischen föderation
das müssen wir jetzt
diese entscheidung haben rund 300
russischstämmige düsseldorf erinnern
bereits getroffen sie demonstrierten
heute auf der königsallee gegen wladimir
putin und seinen angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine wir glauben dass ohne den druck
von europa usa und den europäischen
ländern ist nicht dazu kommen wird dass
dieser krieg aufhört am nachmittag wurde
die beim fedorov von seiner kölner
amtskollegin henriette reker empfangen
sie hatte sich vehement für seine
freilassung aus russischer
gefangenschaft eingesetzt
soweit zum krieg in der ukraine
was im realen leben illegal ist muss es
auch im netz sein hass hetze und betrug
etwa das klingt selbstverständlich ist
es aber nicht die eu hat sich deshalb
auf neue regeln geeinigt diese zum
beispiel online plattformen wie google
oder facebook müssen illegale inhalte
unverzüglich löschen und beim verdacht
auf schwere straftaten die behörden
informieren sie sind auch verpflichtet
nutzer zu sperren die häufig gegen die
regeln verstoßen und sie müssen offen
legen warum ihre algorithmen den nutzern
bestimmte inhalte empfehlen mehr von
gunnar grieger
ein eu schützt vor hass rede und setzt
das digitale dienste gesetz kurz dsa
gegen die internet lobby durch die eu
kommission meint ihr eigenes video wohl
nicht ganz ernst aber ihr anspruch ist
kaum kleiner
showdown war nachts um zwei einigung der
eu institutionen
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
nannte das historisch auf einer der nun
stärker regulierten plattformen
zustimmung von europaabgeordneten
es war notwendig dass wir eine klare
aufsicht auch überblick bekommen und
dass wir auch hass im internet
konsequent bekämpfen können weniger
konsequent ist das gesetz bei der
verknüpfung von daten so sieht ein mann
mitte vierzig weiter personalisierte
werbung nur minderjährige sind davor
künftig besser geschützt
wenig konsequenz auch bei algorithmen
den regeln die bestimmen was nutzer
sehen und damit sie impft debatte auch
meinung nach solche media plattformen
setzen auf angst und wut warum tun sie
das weil die menschen dann länger im
internet bleiben und man kann ihn mehr
werbung zeigen und werbung ist das
geschäftsmodell des internets die
plattform verdienen also mehr geld mit
inhalten die uns polarisieren die uns
aufhetzen dem verdacht dürfen experten
nun per gesetz nachgehen die politik
kann die ergebnisse dann aufgreifen das
gesetz muss seinen anspruch also noch
einlösen in kraft tritt des frühestens
in gut einem jahr
nach nordrhein westfalen
dort wird am 15 mai ein neuer landtag
gewählt und cdu und spd liefern sich ein
kopf an kopf rennen derzeit regieren cdu
und fdp das bevölkerungsreichste
bundesland für eine wiederauflage
scheint es laut umfragen aber nicht zu
reichen rot grün könnte es knapp
schaffen aber am wahrscheinlichsten
scheint ein dreierbündnis heute läutete
die cdu die heiße wahlkampfphase ein mit
ministerpräsident wüst ein bericht von
goldmann
er ist der amtierende ministerpräsident
und will es bleiben hendrik wüst ist cdu
spitzenkandidat in nordrhein westfalen
das amt hatte von armin laschet
übernommen das ist das erste mal dass er
um wählerstimmen werben muss geht jetzt
aus kämpfte um jede stimme überzeugt die
menschen für unser land für die menschen
damit wir gemeinsam machen können worauf
es ankommt auch in den nächsten fünf
jahren auch er will ministerpräsident
werden oppositionsführer und
herausforderer thomas kutschaty hier
beim straßenwahlkampf in hagen seine spd
liegt in den jüngsten umfragen knapp vor
der cdu es gibt rückenwind auch die
umfragen sind guten das beflügelt
natürlich auch unsere wahlkämpferin und
wahlkämpfer reisen auch kein problem
früh morgens um sechs am bahnhof zu
stehen und zu verteilen derzeit regiert
die cdu mit der fdp deren
spitzenkandidat joachim stamm will das
auch weiter tun auch wenn es wohl
schwierig wird mit einer neuauflage von
schwarz gelb unser ziel ist wieder
zweistellig zu werden und das ohne uns
keine mehrheit gebildet werden kann dass
wir weiter ihr für wirtschaftswachstum
für individuelle bildung arbeiten können
laut aktuellen umfragen könnten aber die
grünen mit spitzenkandidatin mona
neubauer die fdp überflügeln eine
regierungsbeteiligung ist nicht
unwahrscheinlich wir sind selbstbewusst
und eigenständig in diesem wahlkampf
unterwegs und wir werden um vertrauen
für unsere gründen inhalte werben und
die dann auch möglichst gewinnbringend
in eine künftige landesregierung
einbringen auch die afd wird wohl wieder
im landtag vertreten sein für
spitzenkandidat markus wagner ist aber
klar eine regierungsbeteiligung mit ihr
will keine der anderen parteien activity
rolle spielen die sie auch in der
letzten legislatur gespielt hat eine
klare opposition gegen die gesamte
heilige vielfältigkeit aus cdu spd fdp
und grünen wir werden dort immer den
finger in die wunde legen einer von
ihnen wird ministerpräsident werden
hendrik wüst oder thomas kutschaty es
muss aber nicht unbedingt der mit den
meisten stimmen sein sondern vielleicht
der denn nach der wahl mit den grünen
und der fdp am besten sondieren kann
zum sport schon heute am viertletzten
spieltag kann der fc bayern zum zehnten
mal nacheinander wohlgemerkt deutscher
fußballmeister werden am anderen ende
tabelle ist ja schon der erste
entscheidung getroffen und das betrifft
viele fußballfans im frankenland denn
für die spielvereinigung greuther fürth
wird das abenteuer bundesliga nach nur
einer saison wieder zu ende gehen die
vorzeitige entscheidung fiel im eigenen
stadion 11.000 zuschauer sehen das 1 4
gegen bayer leverkusen union berlin
revanchiert sich mit dem 2 2 1 in
leipzig für die pokalniederlage freiburg
gegen gladbach 3 zu 3 köln gewinnt gegen
bielefeld 3 2 1 frankfurt gegen
hoffenheim 2 zu 2 die bayern sind auf
meisterkurs zur halbzeit stets gegen
dortmund beziehungsweise kurz vor der
pause zwei zu null gestern wolfsburg
gegen mainz 500 morgen noch zwei spiele
die bayern hat mit einem sieg gegen den
bvb uneinholbare zwölf-punkte-vorsprung
leverkusen jetzt vor leipzig freyburg
dich dran union und köln auf kurs zum
europäischen auftritt mainz jetzt in der
unteren hälfte für gladbach wolfsburg
und bochum ist zumindest der direkte
abstieg kein thema mehr bielefeld wird
gespannt auf das duell der besser
platzierten herthaner und stuttgarter
schauen führt verabschiedet sich am 14
bayern gvb das top spiel schlechthin um
23 uhr ausführlich im aktuellen
sportstudio zu gast ist frankfurts
präsident peter fischer
bereits weltmeister max verstappen
gewinnt in imola das erste sprint rennen
des jahres holt sich damit acht punkte
und die pole-position für den grand prix
morgen nachmittag
der niederländer verpasst den start die
räder drehen durch le claire jetzt vorn
länder norris im mclaren kommt ihm
gefährlich nahe aber nicht vorbei der
ferrari von le claire indes in führung
sebastian vettel wird nur dreizehnter im
grünen erst martin gestern im regen gut
aber seinen neunten startplatz kann er
nicht halten bottas im alfa romeo vorbei
und wenig später überholt ihn auch noch
mit schumacher im ferrari mit rang zehn
im sprint startet schumacher damit beim
grand prix so weit vorne wie noch nie
überraschung am ende das tappen schnappt
sich eine runde vor schluss den sieg im
sprint volle claire und sergio perez
rekordsieger thw kiel steht nach dem 28
26 gegen lemgo zum fünfzehnten mal im
pokalfinale trifft morgen in hamburg im
gipfeltreffen auf bundesliga
spitzenreiter sc magdeburg
die halle ist voll die anfangsphase
torreich und magdeburg in weiß so
souverän wie es der
bundesliga-tabellenführung entspricht
guetsli kristiansson von 13 zu 9 1 4
tore vorsprung der bis zur halbzeit
bleibt da stets 17 13 erlangen kommt
über die außenseiterrolle nicht hinaus
antonio metzner zum 17 14 kleiner wird
der rückstand nicht mehr heißt es trifft
dann zum endstand 30 22 am sonntag im
finale gegen den elfmaligen pokalsieger
kiel hat magdeburg die chance den ersten
von zwei möglichen saison titeln klar zu
machen
dass morgen in der sportstudio reportage
dankeschön an die wetteraussichten die
kommen gleich von katja horneffer so
viele war schon mal vorab die natur die
kann den wegen regen vielerorts brauchen
dennoch regnet es morgen keineswegs
überall das heute-journal läuft heute um
22.45 mit christian sievers auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend island hat eigentlich ein
abo auf tiefs aber derzeit dreht sich
dort ein hoch und die tiefs ziehen über
mitteleuropa schon heute gab es ja
regenschauer und gewitter und in der
zweiten nachthälfte breiten sich
regenfälle von der schweiz und von
frankreich aus über süddeutschland aus
und morgen regnet es dann am längsten
hier im thüringer wald oder auch in
baden württemberg heute nacht ist es
auch mal klar im östlichen sachsen und
zwischen der ostseeküste und dem
sauerland und die temperaturen sinken
auf 10 bis 3 grad die größten
temperaturunterschiede auf engem raum
gibt es morgen in der mitte deutschlands
nur acht grad werden es in der oberpfalz
18 grad dagegen am niederrhein sonst
liegen die temperaturen zwischen 9 und
16 grad und in süddeutschland fällt
häufig regen da bleibt es meist bedeckt
zwischen der mosel dem oberrhein den
thüringer wald und im erzgebirge
zwischen dem bayerischen wald und dem
allgäu aber entwickeln sich schauer und
gewitter bei westwind da sehen sie also
auch mal die sonne viel mehr sonne sehen
sie morgen in norddeutschland da wird es
freundlich bei einem immer noch
kräftigen wind aus nordost wechselhaft
startet dann auch die neue woche aber
bis mittwoch setzt sich dann doch schon
fast überall wieder die sonne durch bei
milderen 12 bis 18 grad schönes
wochenende